pardonnez moi mes bien chers abonnés car
j'ai péché j'ai dans ma dernière vidéo
des bonnes kg pénitence j'ai fait de la
pub à une page internet qui n'avait que
trois mille vue et voilà ce qui arrive
quand quand je m'avance trop voilà
maintenant on a sept mille vu sur une
vidéo qui critique une page internet qui
n'en fait que 3000 voilà donc donc là
j'ai merdé
j'ai merdé sec là je la voulais y à il
ya eu problème là à côté de ça notre
vidéo notre dernière vidéo cette option
celle avec 2500 vu moi je pouvais pas
m'y attendre je pouvais pas m'y attendre
la un tel succès non mais je vous ai
2h14 de souffrance ont plus de vue que
nos vidéos habituelle veut dire est ce
que c'est
c'est quand même c'est quand même
bizarre c'est quand même bizarre donc
donc voilà j'ai décidé de ma fille j'ai
une nouvelle punition une nouvelle
punition une nouvelle pénitence voilà
mon chemin de croix la deuxième étape de
mon chemin de croix un vrai showman
croise à vaduz étape alors je ne suis
pas près d'en sortir bref une deuxième
étape à ce chemin de croix et cette
deuxième étape
j'ai choisi de taper du dans du gros du
lourd barre il faut pas que je refasse
la même connerie en même temps donc
cette fois ci j'ai décidé de prendre une
vidéo et une vidéo qui cette fois a
quelque chose comme 100 89 milles vue
donc on n'est pas loin des 200 milles
vue sur celle là là au moins je suis à
peu près sûr qui est qu'il ya très peu
de chambres pas je suis à peu près sûr
qu'en gros on n'atteindra pas ce niveau
là quoi on n'atteindra pas 189 me lever
à 307 comme 3,307 j'aime sur ce contenu
alors je ne sais pas si c'est des
rigolos bien quoi seulement 77 j'aime
pas j'ai des vidéos qui font mieux que
ça quand même niveau j'aime pages et des
vidéos qui font des sacrés bad buzz
comme celle là par exemple
là on a là on a dû du level de bad buzz
mais non cela ne fait pas de boss
particulièrement donc j'ai décidé de m'y
attaquer alors je me attaque pourquoi
parce que d'une part comme je le disais
je risque pas de faire mieux qu elles
dont et donc nous conservons notre
statut de david face à goliath mais
surtout regarder ce petit logo
regardez ce magnifique logo cette daube
a été diffusé sur france 5
cette daube a eu le droit à une audience
sur une chaîne télé publique
c'est sous des impôts là qui financent
ces chaînes là donc là on est quand même
sur du lourd du très lourd
attendez une vidéo qui s'appelle preuve
de l'existence des géants un reportage
sur preuve de l'existence des gérants ça
va être dur ça va être très dur 49
minutes 32 de ça et il va falloir que je
me l'affligent je fais ça pour vous pour
toi public pour vous mes chers pêcheurs
je me sacrifie sur la grande croix de la
stupidité d'internet c'est parti mon
kiki au attendait avant qu'on démarre
alors regardez voilà un t-rex à paris
donc là il va y avoir un vrai squelette
de tyrannosaure à paris donc pour tous
ceux qui ont vu la vidéo
l'exilé dinosaures n'existe pas et qui
qui sont plutôt rares qui sait il ya
peut-être des sceptiques j'ai pas encore
eu trop de sceptiques dans les
commentaires ça va j'ai eu des insultes
des machins bon de les classiques mais
là pour le coup on à l'exposition un
t-rex à paris qui va vous montrer un
vrai t-rex à paris au musée hommes du
sis aux 2 septembre
voilà revenons-en à notre preuve de
l'existence des géants donc un reportage
qui a été diffusé je sais pas quand en
tout cas c'est depuis 2014 qu'il est sur
internet visiblement en tout cas publiée
par monsieur le mutins de panurge
c'est une vidéo que j'ai quand même eu
le courage de regarder une fois en
entier donc ça va être la deuxième fois
que je me la farsi donc ça va être un
peu moins spontané bon je dis pas que je
vais pas être vulgaire mais ça va être
un peu moins spontané que la précédente
quand même parce qu'il ya quand même des
choses qui a fallu que je revérifie il
ya quand même des des sources qui a
fallu que je trouvais qu'ils étaient pas
forcément facile à trouver
donc ça m'a demandé un premier
visionnage donc voilà ça fait deux fois
que je souffre pour en regardant cette
vidéo pour vous c'est parti
le mythe des géants à sa fonction parce
que
cette musique déjà cette musique en dieu
là tu sens que ça va être du sérieux là
quand on commence avec une musique
latine on grince tarde beaucoup d'autres
civilisations anciennes
les mayas et les incas croyait qu'une
race géantes idée du vienne avait vécu
sur terre
certains les ont pris pour des dieux
d'autres ont gravé leur image dans la
pierre ou les ont mentionné dans des
récits traditionnels les grecs et les
romains on parlait depuis 200 ans
tombant du ciel jusque dans le giron de
gaïa déesse de la terre qui allait
donner naissance au titan une formidable
race de gm
ouais donc en gros tous les peuples tous
les peuples aux anciens ont des légendes
de géant ouais c'est pas non plus le
plus célèbre de tous et sans doute quand
jean introduction issu d'une fratrie de
géant à vache une minute 28 et ça y est
on en est déjà à la bible quand gros
l'introduction là une minute trente pour
nous expliquer qu'en gros des légendes
de géants il y en a partout
suggérant subtilement en filigrane que
c'est pas un hasard s'il ya des légendes
de géants partout dans le monde
c'est certainement parce qu'il y avait
des vrais géants j'imagine que c'est ça
l'idée derrière
oui alors on va être très clair tout de
suite à propos des mythes de géant
les mythes de géant c'est comme les
trous du cul qu'ils aillent tous se
faire [ __ ]
non vraiment vraiment qu'ils à tous se
faire [ __ ] le dira évidemment comme
c'est comme les trous du cul tout le
monde en a des mythes de géant mais
enfin je veux dire j'ai pas besoin de
remonter une civilisation antique pour
trouver des mythes de géant les
afrikaners d'afrique du sud
donc les afrikaners d'afrique du sud
c'est en gros un peuple qui n'existe que
depuis la colonisation donc en gros
après 1500 voilà d'ailleurs ils sont
arrivés plus vers 1600 donc la colonie
du cap a été établi dans les années 1600
donc les années les afrikaners d'afrique
du sud en gros ils sont autant des
peuples antiques que louis xiv 1
voilà en gros c'est ça vous sud est à
peu près ce niveau-là d'antiquités ont
pas un peuple particulièrement qu'on
pourrait suggérer comme particulièrement
mystérieux ou ou différentes nous un
basset afrikaner ils ont une légende
alors c'est attendez je vais essayer de
vous trouver les images mais en gros ils
ont une légende d'un monsieur qui
s'appelle rhyner dans la ville de dans
le village deux astres en en afrique du
sud
et donc ce monsieur rhyner il s'est
battu plusieurs fois avec le diable et
il s'est battu plusieurs fois avec le
diable une fois avec avec son fusil
et il a raté le diable de peu mais il a
fait ce trou là dans la montagne dit la
légende
voilà il ya une montagne à un trou de
dans un camp même on peut trouver
d'autres images sur internet le même
trou par point de vue légèrement
différent donc monsieur rhyner quand il
se bat avec le diable il fait des trous
dans les montagnes donc autant dire que
c'est quand même du massif le bas-rhin
et il ya une autre légende du même
monsieur rhyner se battant une fois de
plus avec le diable sauf que cette fois
c'est lui qui esquive un coup de sabre
du diable et ben en esquivant ce coup de
sabre du diable les montagnes elles sont
décapités ce qui leur donne justement
cet aspect tout plat d'ailleurs regardez
le décapiter comme ça c'est qu à plat
donc donc monsieur rhyner c'était pas un
p'tit gars c'était un bon gros gars hein
et puis toujours en afrique du sud dans
la colonie bas au cap et bien à l'époque
où c'était la colonie du cap et les gens
se demander pourquoi il y avait un gros
nuage au dessus de la montagne de la
table est la raison pour laquelle hop je
vais t'appeler ça en anglais triebel
mountain cloud
voilà il ya toujours une espèce de
nuages qui flotte autour de la montagne
de la table et qui fait cette jolie
cascade que vous voyez des jolies que
jolie cascade de nuages qui tombe alors
nous demande mais pourquoi il ya eu un
gros nuage comme ça bah c'est parce
qu'il ya un pirate géant qui a fait un
concours de fumette avec le diable et du
coup c'est pour ça qu'il ya de la fumée
qui tombe
voilà donc c'est un singe et anti fumée
à cigares géant un pirate géant qu'il
fumait à cigares géant qui une pub
géante je crois plutôt qui a fait 7 ce
nuage
d'après la légende et je vous parle de
légende qui sont apparus forcément après
1600 puisque c'est des légendes
afrikaner donc il ya vraiment pas de
quoi
enfin je veux dire dire que toutes les
cultures ont des géants il n'y a
vraiment pas de quoi on va on pas de
quoi s'étonner
je veux dire avant même si on sait pas
trop pourquoi
culturellement les gens choisissent des
géants plutôt que des dragons c'est à
dire qu'il y ait des cultures dans
lesquelles qui est des cultures très
différentes de la nôtre dans lesquels on
a des jambes deux géants de toute façon
c'est pas une surprise puisque même dans
des cultures très récente
on a des légendes de
deux géants donc ouais les gens ont
tendance à raconter des histoires de
géants assez facilement c'est tout ce
que ça veut dire
voilà c'est tout ce que ça veut dire ah
oui et puis du coup du coup puisqu'on
passe de puisqu'on parle de rider rider
on a ça tombe on a ça tombe aujourd'hui
on peut la voir sa tombe et regardez la
taille de satan mais hélas j'ai pas de
site internet à proposer donc je vous
mets directement la photo voilà ça tombe
elle est de taille normale donc c'est
pas un géant riner pourquoi avoir
inventé une histoire de gerbe parce que
les gens ont tendance à faire ça il
invente rapidement des histoires de gens
qui sont très très grand surtout quand
c'est des héros nationaux j'imagine
c'est toujours mieux de dire qu'ils
étaient vachement grand de taille à
affronter le diable et à couper les
montagnes où elle est rouée bref
donc ouais on a plein de légende c'est
bien qu'au lycée bien que j aurais tant
porter sur ses épaules
si on en croit le midrash l'exégèse
rabbinique de l'écriture sainte
voilà on cite on cite des écritures
saintes comme une source
bibliographiques fiable pour paris de
l'archipel je rappelle que d'après les
écritures saintes la terre formé en six
jours la première femme s'est elle a été
cloné à partir du code d'un homme
jusqu'au camp des philistins or c est ça
se discute quoi ça se discute
c'est ici à 25 km au sud-ouest de la
ville actuelle de jérusalem de goliath
aurait finalement été tués non par un
géant comme la mi mai par david un frêle
jeune homme qui comme les tablettes les
a fait ici qui deviendra plus tard ils
utilisent encore le conditionnel à ce
niveau-là de la vidéo donc ça va ça va
oui j'essaie de générer un espèce
d'effet
or le mystère des merveilles sont
formidablement le mec il croit
nécessaire quand même de nous rappeler
ce que c'est que la légende de david et
goliath quoi il a roulé comme ça et il a
enroulé autour de son bras c'est
formidable
avait-on armure dont boucliers ton épée
mais moi je viens au nom du dieu
d'israël
donc on est d'accord que dans son sac
l'archéologue il nous raconte une
histoire qui a rien à voir avec
l'archéologie en et de l'accord classe c
au mieux de la mythologie
le jeune verger a assommé qui lie avec
cette fronde mais il ne l'a pas tué
goliat est tombé à genoux david s'est
penché sur lui il n'y aura jamais p
quand est ce qui réduit aux philippines
chasse il a décapité le jeu
[Musique]
à trois kilomètres seulement de
l'endroit où ce combat emblématique se
seraient déroulés se dresse un gros
cumulus de 25 m on dit que c'est là que
repose et goliath mais comme personne
n'a jamais creusé à laver sont censés ya
un tumulus mais comme par hasard on sait
pas ce qu'il ya dessous en amérique dans
les régions du midwest
on trouve également de nombreux
monticule imposant a su plage j'attire
votre attention sur les coupures de
presse à les auteurs à succès bref c'est
tiger a consacré auteur à succès jomic
des géants
donc voilà ce que monsieur brad styger s
est un auteur à succès donc il est aussi
pertinent que stephen king
j'aime beaucoup on peut aimer un stephen
king mais il a la même pertinence au
niveau de ce sujet là que monsieur
stephen king continue ou dan brown tient
pour prendre des gens qui font don dans
les théories ésotérique
on a ouvert certaines de ces tombes on a
constaté que les hommes mesure on a
constaté qu'ils aient honte de m'être
disent certains d'individus atteignant 3
mètres et de crin extrêmement volume
mais ce qui est le plus extraordinaire
c'est que certains de ces crânes avaient
des sorte de corne
d'autres des rangées de dents supplément
d'envié d'autres encore présenter ce que
la coupure de presse mais c'est un
copieur de près cela ne montre rien de
ce qu'il est en train de dire peu comme
dernier et cooper ne presse pas d'image
david childress archéologue et écrivain
est depuis longtemps fassi à monsieur
davinci dresse archéologue et écrivain
donc ouais il est à moitié pertinent du
coup c'est quoi est ce que faire deux
choses à la fois c'est pas le meilleur
moyen de rater les deux comme dirait de
mecs dans taxi
non moi aussi je prends des références
culturelles de fou puisque apparemment
les références c'est pas l'heure que
c'est pas leur truc quoi donc moi aussi
je peux prendre des références un peu
d'eau hbe tout le monde a le droit mais
attendez qu'on revienne sur ses coupures
de presse je pense que c'est important
de revenir sur ces coupures de presse
parce que là honnêtement il y avait il y
avait à boire et à manger
donc on voit dans ces coupures de presse
il ya qu une seule image déjà qui
apparaît par rapport dans le reportage
lui-même n'y a qu'une seule image il n'y
a pas d'échelle donc on nous parle de
crâne géant
on peut pas savoir il n'y a pas
d'échelle et on nous dit qu'il ya une
doublure des double rangée de dents on
nous parle de cornes etc
il nous le montre pas donc en gros si tu
veux en savoir plus votre démerder bon
j'ai fini j'ai quand même trouvé quelque
chose pour essayer d'en savoir plus et
me démerder
donc voici un site qui est qui
répertorie quelques quelques images
m'ont alors je sais pas d'où il tire ces
images là mais voilà il n'y a pas
d'échelle de toute façon donc ça nous
avance à rien on parle de gigantisme
on est bien d'accord que le moindre des
choses c'est quand même de [ __ ] une
échelle regardez ça n'y a pas d'échelle
là dessus donc on voit rien donc le
géant des dunes de géorgie ouais bah
voila moi si j'ai envie de si j'ai envie
d'en savoir plus ce qu'est ce que je
fais bah bah je vais me faire voir
je vais me faire voir là on montre un
squelette de soi disant géant joua les
gens à côté ils ont pas l'air j'ai
plutôt l'impression que le squelette il
est petit en réalité je vois pas où
loger ans donc je vais pas aller à
travers tous les textes parce que
honnêtement voilà il ya soixante et des
articles de presse dont qui a rien à en
tirer au final pas étant donné la
précision de la presse quand il s'agit
de science aujourd'hui j'ai pas envie de
croire qu'à l'époque c'était beaucoup
plus intéressant donc là ouais voilà on
a des géants sait très bien qui nous
disent qu'ils étaient exceeding li hai
donc voilà c'est tout ce qu'on sait
c'est qu'ils sont très grands pas
d'échelle à ces squelettes toujours pas
you just colton donc des gros squelette
mais pas de rien ne rien de plus rien de
plus précis seven fit donc on est les
squelettes font sept pieds de long enfin
sept pieds de haut en l'occurrence vrai
trop admettre un homme normal en fait si
ce donc
sept pieds de long s'est pas non plus
par an + gyr si gigantesque que ça un
pied donc lettre ouverte convertissons
one foot to one missed à notre petit
convertisseur google nous dit que à pied
c'est voilà trente centimètres presque
31 donc voilà ça fait juste un 30 cm de
plus que la taille moyenne d'un homme
c'est pas non plus la fin du monde
voilà alors dit squelette dit squelettes
ont été retrouvés de huit pieds a mis
pied ça commence à faire un peu mieux
mais bon une pièce ça reste dans la
taille on va juste retourner voir je
crois que c'était wadi nos son nom voilà
oui robert toit de l'eau robert wadlow
regardez la taille qui faisait dire on
reste dans la gamme de la variation
humaine
monsieur wayne law il était quand même
c'était un être humain je veux dire
autant que l'on puisse s'en souvenir je
veux dire c'était un être humain il n'a
jamais été considéré comme autre chose
qu'un être humain et il faisait huit
pieds voilà c'est marqué ici mes pieds
et on se couche
il a donc de mettre 72 voilà là on reste
même
même en admettant que les squelettes
faisait effectivement hui bien il n'ya
pas non plus de quoi
mettez trois pattes à un canard donc on
continue une race de géant a vécu en
amérique
des squelettes de sept pieds d'eau a
enfin une photo avec une échelle donc
qui avec un crâne avec une échelle qui
fait 1 2 3 4 5 6 pouces alors est ce que
c'est on peut dire que le crâne là il
doit faire à peu près huit couches donc
in tout cinq teams et heures
m me pousse ça fait bien 20 cm bon un
crâne humaine 20 cm j'ai à peu près ça
n'ait pas été trois pattes à un canard
une fois de plus un crâne humain qui
fait 20 cm de long excusez moi mais
c'est comme ça un peu c'est même un peu
short en réalité un crâne humain de 22
cm c'est comme ça qu'est ce qui nous
raconte la halle avec leurs géants a
encore une image avec une échelle mais
enfin là c'est quand même vachement
comment dire apparemment en plus c'est
même pas un vrai truc qui fait c'est ils
sont en train de construire une
reconstruction
c'est même pas le vrai squelette là qui
montre c'est juste une restauration sept
pieds des indiens géant mais parce qu'il
s'agit de squelettes d'indian américain
évidemment ce n'est pas c'est pas des
squelettes des blancs qui sont qui font
cette pièce et des disques et des deux
navires d'amérique non parce que ça aura
son importance a son importance et je
vais vous dire pourquoi c'est parce que
les les gens qui ont débarqué en
amérique
les colons les tout premiers âges parler
des tout premiers juste après christophe
colomb ils avaient des histoires plein
la tête des histoires comme quoi le
monde avait été peuplée de géant
et ça je vous renvoie à notre vidéo qui
s'appelle justement enquête sur les
géants du passé enquête sur les géants
du passé le parce que c'est pas notre
première vidéo sur les gens et donc dans
cette vidéo enquête sur les géants du
passé on vous explique que
historiquement en fait les européens ont
toujours cru que il des êtres humains
étaient descendus d'une race de géant
qui avaient ratissé au fil du temps et
donc trouvé que les américains que les
américains indiens les amérindiens sont
des géants et ben ça confirme royalement
cette hypothèse
et en plus ça fait passer les
amérindiens pour ce qu'ils croyaient
qu'ils étaient à l'époque c'est à dire
des gens primitif ouï dire que les
indiens sont été géant c'est raciste
mais bien comme il faut
les genres bien comme il faut ceci dit
avec les théories des pyramides you on
n'est pas mieux puisqu'on on dit que il
ya des peuples juste sous prétexte
qu'ils sont pas européens il était
incapable de faire quoi que ce soit de
leurs dix doigts
donc c'est la même chose avec les
pyramides you c'est juste du racisme
c'est parce qu'ils sont pas européens
alors ils peuvent pas faire la même
chose que nous bon bah là on flirte dans
les mêmes rôles à honfleur dans des eaux
où au final les on pensait que les
indiens étaient primitif et vu qu'ils
étaient primitif et ben on
il fallait qu'on les trouve plus grand
qu'ailleurs donc voilà c'est c'est sale
c'est très sale
moi je trouve je suis pas le premier à
le dire évidemment mais ça je vais vous
montrer un petit peu après non c'est
alors vous du coup ce qu'il ya
d'intéressant c'est qu'il y a des
témoignages de gens qui disent avoir vu
à l'époque de la colonisation des
amériques des gens qui prétendent avoir
vu des indiens qui était plus grand que
la moyenne qui était vachement grands
qu'ils étaient des géantes
mais bon leurs récits étaient
certainement pas il n'est pas impossible
d'exclure que leurs récits et des
teintée d'une certaine certaines prix
conception de ce qui est censé être un
peuple primitif à leurs yeux bon
continue juste avec les coupures de
presse pas de photo pas de photos ni
piécettes pied un extraordinaire rien
d'extraordinaire bla bla bla ah non là
on a eleven fit 11 pieds à là on
commence là tu commence à m'intéresser
c'est dommage que t'es pas de photos
c'est dommage que vous ayez pas non plus
de vrais articles de presse parce que là
là ça nous aurait quand même bien aidé
là pour le coup alors on va essayer
d'être de trouver un article de
véritables articles de presse
scientifique je veux dire évidemment
quand je lis les articles de presse
encore une fois pas deux là encore une
fois il n'ya pas de les gens n'y a pas
d'échelle là il n'y a pas d'échelle non
plus
là on accumule lui son essence y
comprendre quoi ce juste un gourou tunis
est très bien merci
des gros cumulus on en a fait pour des
gens qui on savait être de taille
normale donc pourquoi ce serait une
preuve de quoi que ce soit non par
contre ça m'a pris un peu de temps mais
j'ai fini par trouver un article giants
indians sont giant amérindiens aux
facteurs fantasy là on peut pas mieux au
niveau 6 1 les âmes les amérindiens
géant fait ou histoire ou invention donc
alors dans cet article ce qu'il ya de
formidable c'est qu'il ya quelqu'un qui
a fait des mesures
bah oui il a trouvé des squelettes lui 1
bizarrement il avait des squelettes sous
la main contrairement à tous ses
journalistes là et il a fait des mesures
et il a en mesurant les les indiens
d'amérique
il a constaté que effectivement
donc si je remonte un petit peu
effectivement les amérindiens avait une
taille moyenne d'environ 170 cm 170 cm
sachant qu'à l'époque la taille moyenne
c'était en dessous de ça 1
là on part on parle du début de la
colonisation donc au début de la
colonisation les les amérindiens faisait
faisait 170 cm dans un monde où les gens
devaient atteindre un mètre cinquante à
mettre 60 grand maximum en allégeant les
européens devaient atteindre un mètre
cinquante à mettre 60 ont effectivement
il est possible quand même qu'il ya un
fond de vérité dans ces histoires de
géant que les colons aurait vu c'est
juste qu'ils étaient un peu plus haut
que la moyenne d'ailleurs 170 cm je
crois que c'est toujours un peu plus
haut que la moyenne
donc oui bon après il faut prendre une
petite marge d'erreur dû au fait que
c'est basé sur des squelettes la tête à
fond de vérité peut-être
qu'effectivement en arrivant sur les
côtes des les européens les ont trouvés
très grand et que un peu plus tard en
revenant raconter les histoires il en
est fait des tonnes
en y rajoutant leur croyance en général
sur le fait qu'il y avait des géants
avant et que du coup comme les
amérindiens sont un peuple primitif à
leurs yeux et ben ils sont forcément
plus grand parce que ce sont forcément
des géants parce que ils sont plus
primitifs puisque le l'être humain
rapetisse
bon déjà il nous explique qu'il ya eu
pas mal de hawx est évidemment dans le
tas il ya eu défaut il yal'idée
supercherie dans le tas notamment le
fameux géante cardiff 1 qui en fait
n'était fait enfin dont la poule a
soi-disant de pau a été analysé et
finalement s'est révélé être de la gelée
1 donc faut pas non plus faut pas non
plus prendre pour argent comptant que
tous ces squelettes étaient des vrais
déjà et après ce qu'il nous dit donc
c'est que les fort possible que ces
géants mais juste jamais existé mais il
faut pas oublier qu'à l'époque justement
la perception c'était qu'il y avait des
géants publics
je me permets un petit rajout post
montage parce que je remarque que j'ai
beaucoup digresser donc en gros ce qu'il
ya à retenir de tout ça c'est que 1
les seules traces de géant cité par
cette vidéo sont dans des coupures de
tabloïds qui ont donc très très peu de
valeur au niveau scientifique
généralement pas accompagné d'image ou
s'il ya une image elle manque d'une
échelle après pour ce qu'on a deux
squelettes d'amérindiens dans les
collections des musées aucun d'eux n'est
géante bizarrement s'il y avait des
amérindiens géant en tout cas c'est pas
ce qu'on a conservées dans les musées
quoiqu'en fait pas mal d'entre eux soit
un peu plus grand que la moyenne et
enfin la notion même que les amérindiens
étaient des géants est raciste puisque
elle se base sur la vieille croyance que
les populations du monde rapetissent et
que les a bien en tant que peuple perçu
comme primitif devait forcément être dg
en continuant la vidéo et en numérique à
rire écoutons l'archéologue écrivains de
fouilles à partir de 1850 un certain
nombre de tumulus ont fait l'objet de
pillage dans les années 1950
je corrige un peu les propos de monsieur
on va trouver des squelettes des
passants de m donc rien de
particulièrement 2010 rien de
particulièrement en danger de double
double rangée de dents mais toujours pas
d'image qui doit et six orteils
voilà donc votre preuve des six doigts à
chaque main c'est c'est un dessin merci
la preuve la preuve que que le
schtroumpf grincheux existe je vous
l'approuvent n'importe quand bossi ça va
être comme ça
l'un des squelettes a été enlevé par un
groupe de mineurs la bride albin il faut
donc voilà deux mineurs pas
d'archéologues a découvert ce mur avec
des sortes d'inscription il oublie fille
ils pensaient trouver de l'or hier
voilà donc des chercheurs d'or qui
défonce un site archéologique un pad et
archéologue ah oui regardez ce vol ce
monsieur posé à côté de son géant indien
bon alors ça faut se méfier de ce genre
d'image 1 parce que vous avez vu l'image
elle n'est pas cadrée est pas cadrée sur
les pieds un et garder
regardez voilà la photo en question
allait la bomba n'est pas cadrée sur les
pieds donc faut faire attention avec ça
si vous regardez celle là par exemple
regarder ah oui il est effectivement
très très grand ce intervient en
admettant qu'il soit vrai encore une
fois ouais enfin regarder il est sur la
pointe des pieds
d'une part il est sur la pointe des
pieds et de deux il est sur un petit
pedestal donc en gros une fois tous à
enlever déjà on est sur quelque chose de
moindre rang après c'est peut-être un
très grand individus certes
certainement que ça ramène juste la
hauteur de l'épaule à la hauteur de la
tête du monsieur là mais bon voilà c'est
à partir de là c'était tellement on
n'est plus tellement j'ai en point de
vue là alors là où il faut se méfier
aussi c'est regarder c'est le encore
mieux c'est celle là donc il reprend la
même image sauf que lé cadre et sur le
mec qui est pas sur le même plan que la
momie est né ce mec là là il est sur le
même plan que la momie mais celui là il
est un peu en retrait et eux ils sont
encore plus vicieux de heads up il le
met en arrière et il coupe un peu le
pedestal donc faut vraiment être très
méfiant de ce point de vue là regardez
on a une femme géante cardiff qui s'est
révélé être en gélatine
donc ouais non n'ont pas convaincu
toujours pas non pas pour eux mais pour
la postérité avec un squelette de femme
tenant un enfant recouverts de fourrures
dans une drôle de bouzid rôle de
poussière ni modifiées de grande taille
similaire à ce qu'on avait trouvé au
texas dans la vallée de la mort et que
l'on a trouvé un encore une coupure de
presse l'orner sans images de vieilles
photographies et des coupures de
journaux voler ta mais laissez pas votre
coupure de journal devant la vieille
photographie aussi le journaliste du
mince récompensé par un grand prix du
journalisme en voilà on a eu stephen
king diamond donc maintenant on n'achète
pas l'auteur de twilight s'intéresse
tout particulièrement aux auteurs de
fifty scheidegg grève ou présente
tables âge d'or pour l'archéologie mais
non c'était du pillage tu viens de le
dire enfin je veux dire c'est des
chercheurs d'or qui ont massacré les
trucs tu trouvé quelque chose mais ce
qui est intéressant c'est que c'est ce
que les ossements retrouvés ne peuvent
être circonscrit à une région bien
précise en grèce en italie au
moyen-orient ouais non non non mec t'as
oublié de lire un truc tu as oublié un
train de lire un truc qui s'appelle le
bouquin d'adrienne mayor sur les first
face aux panthers
je suis désolé d'en revenir là mais
encore une fois tout a été dit dans ce
bouquin c'est les fameux géant de voilà
le first person shooters donc les fameux
géant dont il parle à la presse le
moyen-orient tout ça tout est dans le
bouquin et tout est expliqué en plus de
ça si vous êtes un peu trop flemmard
pour lire le l'anglais vous pouvez lire
aussi les recherches sur les ossements
fossiles de cuvier ou cuvier parle
justement de tous ces géants qui ont
soit disant été retrouvé en tout cas
avant son époque à lui aidé avance de
phase iii centers est beaucoup plus à
jour de ce point de vue là mais moi ils
cuvier déjà disait que ouais on a soi
disant retrouvé des géants n'ont en fait
c'étaient des éléphants donc merci de
citer vont enfin merci d'être à jour les
gars s'il vous plaît et même si vous
examinez tout ce qui ressemble aux
interprétations quelque chose comme ça
vous vous retrouvez quand même avec un
nombre considérable de preuves montrant
qu'il ya bien eu des étrangers non
même en éliminant les canulars et les
mauvaises interprétations tout ce qui
reste c'est des trucs pas assez clair
1912 tout ce qu'il reste c'est des trucs
pas assez clair pour être interpréter
correctement comme aux coupures de
presse à dos rond à lhassa investir
cette grotte isolée près de lovelock
dans le nevada pour récupérer les
déjections de chauve souris et les ut il
a donc encore des archéologues
je tiens à préciser on est face à des
archéologues professionnels qui sont
allé déterrer
guano pour en faire de l'engrais non non
c'était encore des mineurs dès mineurs
des gens qui ont massacré un site
archéologique
bon c'est pas leur faute je veux dire
c'étaient des pionniers c'était des
pionniers leur américain et voilà si
c'était pas non plus conscient de ce
qu'il faisait et puis les indiens il en
avait un peu rien à cirer
enfin jeudi le pionnier nom s'était
brisé les 50 en plus enfin c'était au
début du pas dans les années 50 mais au
début du 20e siècle donc en plus je dis
des conneries non en plus vous n'avez
même pas des excuses
à l'intérieur une surprise les attend là
ont fait naître le mystère quand ils ont
commencé à creuser la couche de
déjections de trois à quatre mètres
d'épaisseur qui se trouvait dans la
grotte ils ont trouvé des objets curieux
objet curieux notamment des leurs
opposants des canards accueille ces
mystérieuses samistes arrière des
paniers et puis ils ont fait des
découvertes président habituel ils ont
trouvé des géants modifie avec des
chevaux qui mesurait environ deux mètres
de m 10 geraghty momifié achevé rodney
et il avait de longs cheveux descendant
jusqu'aux épaules explique tout cela
c'était la chose la plus étrange qui a
visité des fermes hier c'était même pas
des mineurs il ya des indiens bail-out
qui lui fait on se croit on connaissait
bien l'histoire en 1883 sahraouis namouh
cas princesse indienne de cette tribu
avait écrit un livre intitulé vivre
parmi les pailles août
dans cet ouvrage elle parlait des géants
aux cheveux roux qui voulez vous à bord
de ce lac et dans ces grottes elle
expliqué que c'étaient des cannibales
évidemment c'est toujours les autres les
cannibales je sais c est quand on est
face à un truc qu'on est qu'on ne
connaît pas c'est toujours les autres
les cannibales alors mon peuple a amassé
du bois pour boucher l'entrée de leur
grotte et ya mis le feu
les miens leur ont demandé de se rendre
sinon une moue vrai mais aucune réponse
n'est parvenue
aujourd'hui l'un des grands mystères de
l'ouest c'est de savoir ce que sont
devenus ces géants
alors moi je vais te le dire ce qu'ils
sont devenus ces géants moi je vais te
le dire mon grand en une fois de plus
adrienne mayor american faux soleure
hunters
voilà donc ce bouqala je refais de la
pub pour toujours les mêmes choses mais
en même temps c'est toujours les mêmes
arguments qui reviennent et c'est
toujours les mêmes gens qui n'ont pas lu
les bonnes histoires
donc voilà fassoles legends of the first
american adrian mayor parle de cette
légende est dit que effectivement des
momies ont été retrouvés dans cette
grotte qu'effectivement il y avait une
légende des indiens payet qui disaient
que c'étaient des géants et qui sait et
qui s'était fait brûler en l'occurrence
il sait plus l'odeur de guano qui
rappelant l'odeur du brûlé qui aurait
inspiré la légende comme quoi il aurait
cramé ces gens là puisqu'en réalité ils
étaient ils ont été momifiées bien avant
ça bien avant les indiens pas du tout
mais bon les indiens payet aurait trouvé
du coup ces momies 1 et effectivement
les momies était bel et bien rousse
elles sont rousse comme les mammouths et
comme les momies de mammouth son rousse
comme les momies égyptiennes aussi il ya
beaucoup de momies égyptiennes qui sont
mus voir blonde
pourquoi parce que la ménade mélanine se
désintègre avec le temps et c'est la
mélanine qui donne la couleur brune aux
cheveux donc oui trouver une momie
rousse en amérique du nord je peux
comprendre que ça ait choqué des gens
mais en réalité c'est juste un effet de
la décomposition de la mélanine sait
rien d'autre
donc on sait très bien ce qu'elles sont
devenues ces momies ces momies elles ont
été découverts donc au début des années
1900 et elles ont été exposées pour de
l'argent jusque dans les années 50 60
et c'est dans les années 50-60 il ya des
scientifiques des vrais scientifiques
cette fois qu'ils se sont intéressés à
elle et qui ont établi comme
l'expliquent adrienne mayer dans son
bouquin que c'était juste des gens de
taille normale voilà
dire ça ils ont elles ont été vues ces
mots miel ont été étudiés elles n'ont
pas été ignoré par les scientifiques
comme certains aimeraient vouloir le
faire croire et voilà l'histoire finit
donc non encore une fois intéressez-vous
à la littérature à la littérature
rédigés par des professionnels voilà
adrienne mayor qui est une véritable
historienne elle pas un auteur à succès
le on a sorti près de 60 squelette de
cette grotte mais on ne sait pas où ils
sont passés
on a sorti 60 que l'aide de cette grotte
on ne sait pas où ils sont passés
retenez bien y at il une tentative de
dissimulation archéologiques dans cette
région quelque chose concernant le géant
tentative de dissimulation
archéologiques ça y est on est à huit
minutes 47 et on a le droit au couplet
sur la tentative de dissimulation
archéologiques le complot mesdames et
messieurs le complot et ben non il n'y a
pas eu de tentative de dissimulation
archéologiques ce qui s'est passé à la
fin des années 60 c'est que c'est que
les âmes et les amérindiens sont devenus
très très chatouilleux concernant leur
culture et est ce que les blancs en
avait fait donc ils ont ré enterré
prompte aux les trucs qui avait été
déterré voir à gg est ce qu'il faut
vraiment que j'explique que quand on
déterre ta grand mère pour aller l'a
montré contre de l'argent en prétendant
que c'est un géant primitif est ce qu
est ce qu il faut vraiment que
j'explique que ça a choqué voilà et que
les amérindiens étaient pas contents du
tout qu'on montre leur ancêtre de cette
façon et parce que c'est évidemment ce
n'est pas le seul cas où c'est arrivé et
vous avez bien vu toutes les coupures de
presse de tous les gens qui ont prétendu
avoir déterré des des indiens géant je
veux dire le géant de cardiff c'était un
autre exemple encore voilà je veux dire
évidemment que tu des terres les tuent
des terres la grand-mère de
des gens et que tu la montre pour de
l'argent en prétendant qu'il s'agit d'un
monstre deux fois évidemment qu'ils vont
te tomber dessus en te disant denture en
termes à grand-mère pronto évidemment
donc non il n'y a pas eu une tentative
de dissimulation archéologiques il ya
juste une ya juste le respect quoi c'est
juste du respect bah oui là ça si on
oublie la phase de l'histoire où les
machins été montré pour de l'argent
parce que je rappelle qu encore une fois
c'est pas des archéologues qui les ont
trouvés là en l'occurrence et des
fermiers bah évidemment qu'on passe à
côté de l'information et qu'on se met à
croire des théories du complot mais n'y
a pas de complot alors aujourd'hui c'est
même devenu presque un problème pour les
archéologues parce que vu qu'il ya des
gens qui ont abusé
ben maintenant les archéologues à chaque
fois qu'il était un squelette d'indiens
et qu'ils essaient de l'étudier pour
comprendre un premier un peu mieux
l'histoire des peuplements en amérique
du nord
même quand le squelette à jordy 1000
voire douze mille ans ben les indiens
leur tombe dessus en disant nananan vous
recommencez pas comme il ya cinquante
balais à faire vos conneries vous
rentrent rsa tout de suite et avec avec
une cérémonie digne de ce nom
cérémonie indienne en l'occurrence après
il ya plein de culture chez les indiens
évidemment mais je vais pas c'est pas le
moment de discuter tout ça mais voilà
pourrait enterrer sa avec les honneurs
s'il vous plaît mais non monsieur est un
je sais pas je vais commencer à être
vulgaire voilà monsieur est un gros
connard de texans qui comprend pas ce à
quoi vous qui avez pas cherché à
comprendre du mois
voilà ton complot tu te lemay aux fesses
avec une légende locale d'être aussi
comme des dizaines de tonnes de semences
de bison ces restes humains ou qui a été
brûlée et est utilisé comme engrais avec
les déjections de chauves souris pour
une fois peut-être que c'est une
explication chorale et deux disparus
aaaaah attendait des éléments toute
preuve toutes preuves relatives à ces
squelettes a disparu alors peut-être
pour les indiens n'ont déjà pas ce qu'on
a on a plein de squelettes de l'époque
précoloniale dans les musées en amérique
du nord et il ya des gens qui ont fait
des études qu'ils ont démontré une sur
la taille de ces squelettes alors est ce
que comme par hasard c'est ceux des
géants qui aurait été fini brûlé
c'est à dire d'ailleurs j'en profite
j'en profite pour faire la remarque mais
monsieur fait la remarque de monsieur
l'écrivent archéologues fait la remarque
que nous y aurait-il eu dissimulation
archéologiques
j'ai envie de dire ouais mais à qui
profite le crime
si admettons qu'ils aient eu
dissimulation machin f s à qui profite
le crime
est-ce que ça profite aux archéologues
qui perdent une partie de l'histoire
qu'ils essayent si désespérément de
reconstituer ou est-ce que ça ou est-ce
que ça profite à l'écrivent archéologues
vendeurs de best seller qui peut
construire les théories du complot et
sans avoir à fournir de preuves parce
que ça me dédouane complètement le mec
il dit ah il ya eu dissimulation
archéologiques plouf plouf
pas besoin de fournir de preuves voilà
c'est pas moi c'est eux c'est le comble
au banon suisse est un peu simple c'est
vraiment trop simple ça non
si on cherche vraiment à comprendre à
qui profite le crime jeu désolé profite
autant aux archéologues qui essaierait
de dissimuler la vérité que cal écrivain
à succès qui essayent de vendre ses
bouquins d'ailleurs y en a un qui se
fait de la tune dans le stade beaucoup
plus directement que les archéologues
donc à qui profite le crime s'est pas
exactement ton argument plus percutant
jacky donc oui l'épreuve l'épreuve ont
disparu ou non c'est pas que les preuves
ont disparu grand c'est que tu ne
cherches pas
encore l'occurrence si on va voir ma
petite vidéo que j'ai fait
28 minutes bon ça fait encore ça encore
du contenu
si on va voir cette vidéo de 28 minutes
et bien des preuves de des géants du
passé il y en a encore y'en a encore
parce qu'il ya des restes qui ont été
trouvés en europe notamment et qui ont
été conservés les proprement qui n'ont
pas dû être enterré parce qu'il
s'agissait de restes indiens qui ont été
pillés donc georges cuvier tac dont
voici le portrait on a étudié un certain
nombre qui ont disparu depuis hélas met
lui même en a étudié un certain nombre
certain nombre qui c'est qui se sont
révélés être des restes de proboscidiens
alors je passe sur les photomontages
pourri mais voilà si voilà par exemple
le géant de l'abbaye de crem menster
donc géant qui aura été découvert en
1645 et voici une image de ce géant de
la baie la dent de ce géant de l'abbaye
de crème aux masters et voici à côté de
cette dans une bande mammouth
voilà donc et c'est dedans elle a été
étudiée du coup par des paléontologues
donc une fois de plus s'est passé pas
que les archéologues dissimule sais
juste que quand il ya des géants s'il ya
des preuves qui restent bas on va les
voir on va les voir et on constate que
c'est rien d'autre que les choses qui
sont déjà connus c'est pas des géants
après il ya donc je m'étale dans cette
vidéo sur l'histoire justement de toto
baucus août et au togo fusse t autofocus
dont on a fini par retrouver les restes
au muséum d'histoire naturelle de paris
il reste plus grand chose à regarder
reste un bout de fémur et un os très
facile à identifier par contre ce qu'on
a c'est une dent il nous reste une dent
et cette dent vous pouvez voir qu'il
s'agit pas du tout d'une dent humaine là
en l'occurrence c'est s'agit pas d'une
dent humaine géante
c'est une dent qui a de l'ofs donc ces
deux structures qui sont ici mises en
avant par les traits rouges et cette
dent en fait elle correspond beaucoup
plus à celle encore une fois d'un
éléphant dino terium en l'occurrence
dont il s'agit d'un éléphant du miocène
chez qui on retrouve justement c'est de
l'ofs
donc voilà il y en a des géants comme ça
je pourrais vous parler aussi
enfin il y en a des géants des restes de
géant qui restent qui sont encore là qui
sont dans les musées qui peuvent être
vues examiné par les scientifiques et à
chaque fois que ça se produit
et bien tout ce qu'on a tout ce qu'on a
cédé simplement des proboscidiens ou des
choses qui sont déjà connus mais
certainement où des êtres humains de
taille normale en réalité qui sont
produites ou géant c'est juste pas des
jeunes en quoi c'est tout et donc allons
chercher maintenant du côté alors il ya
mes collègues
marco romano qui a étudié aussi la
question des géants donc il ya tout un
art ça c'est des gros biceps ça voilà le
squelette des cyclopes et l'estrie bon
donc il a fait tout un article sur des
mésinterprétation les mauvaises
interprétations qui ont été faits de ces
géants hop on va voir l'article complet
dans ce dans cet article là il décrit
tout un tas de casser une revue de
l'état de l'art fait en 2017 avant que
c'est quand même assez récent
c'est quand même suffisamment récent
pour être autres pour mériter d'être
cité donc voilà ça c'était un géant ça
c'était interprété comme une bande géant
en réalité ça c'est typiquement la forme
d'une dent de cheval donc si je marque
or stouff là bas non évidemment il
montre une carte en touche voilà là on
voit très bien
une bande cheval voilà la dame en
question
la dame en question l'ade en cheval a
nié que le dessin là en gros c'est un
peu pas de même
puis la hauteur de la couronne aussi
c'est la même veut dire les seins nus
massa bra une couronne dentaire aussi
être que ça qu'on pourra arrêter les
dents elles sont conscientes que ça chez
l'homme voilà on voit là une un de ces
géants vous voyez quand il reste des
traces des dessins des choses comme ça
c'est très facile à interpréter
donc là ce qui était impressionnant
c'est qu'il avait réussi à retrouver un
autre os voilà c'est tout cela qui
s'avère en fait être un fémur de
mammouth
voilà et qui était interprétée comme le
boss de géant
voilà delà de vienne en l'occurrence et
après il y avait aussi le géant de balle
si je me rappelle bien la faute de
l'écrit en allemand the ride
ouais non c'est pas de balle ces deux
raids donc le géant de raiden reisen
dryden dont voici une reconstitution qui
a été fait à l'époque où il a été trouvé
donc voyez un homme de belle stature bas
en réalité il en reste encore des
morceaux si cette hausse là et en
l'occurrence il me semble que c'est la
capsule à c'est-à-dire l'omoplate d'un
mammouth
voilà donc vous voyez les gens voici les
gens qui ont retrouvé les ossements n'y
a pas que l'omoplate d'ailleurs il ya
d'autres ossements qui ont été retrouvés
qui ont été formellement identifiés
comme du mammouth
donc voilà des légers ans quand on se
donne la peine de les chercher on les
trouve et il n'y a pas de doute sur le
fait qu'il s'agisse jamais dumas géant
à chaque fois c'est très facilement
identifiables comme étant autre chose
dans un individu d'une taille très
inhabituel ah oui balla balla là de
toute façon c'est là où le reportage
commence à faire n'importe quoi
puisqu'il part dans un délire très
proche de celui d amérique latine des
personnages delà de la truck des
pyramides
comment ça s'appelle il est très
difficile de dire ce qu'il représente
mais vu du ciel
voilà le l'équateur pencher et puis le
mystère des pyramides quoi notre cher
ami jacques primeau
voilà si ils ont dessiné des grands
personnages par terre c'est forcément
que ses personnages étaient réellement
géant
j'imagine que c'est ça la logique non
mais sérieusement peut pas dessiner des
gros trucs sans ça les géoglyphes de
cheyrou unità sérieusement plus de 90
mètres de hauteur c'est apparemment la
plus grande représentation de figures
humaines dans le monde qu'il a sculpté
et pourquoi nous n'en savons rien bah si
lena ce cas c'est un peuple qui a existé
dont on a des traces dans ses yeux qu'il
est en difficulté d'angleterre d'autres
figures géante contemple elle aussi le
ciel oh [ __ ] on va faire le siers et
des sols de serna basse c'est mieux que
stone age ou gravées dans une collines
calcaires personne ne sait quand à la
colline de stern abbas dans le dorset
alors oui on va giants d'orsay le géant
du d'orsay qui a fait le géant du
d'orsay nous apprécier quand même le
souci du détail un là il ya du il ya du
grand art donc voilà une histoire donc
hop donc les ordis à cannes ce c'est à
dire dès les premières le premier un
premier compte-rendu si je puis dire
donc on part à la recherche d'un gros
d'un peuple qui aurait vu il ya très
longtemps cela comme par exemple les
romains voilà dans le dorset les romains
auraient pu le voir jules césar aurait
pu voir ces figures du mal à les ratés
visiblement vu qu'elles sont géante et
comme tellement de ses figures fait de
calcaire dans la campagne anglaise celle
de le géant de cernes abbas souvent
pensé comme étant une très vieille
création quelque chose qui a dessiné été
désigné il ya longtemps
néanmoins comme tant de ses figures
aucune histoire ne peut être tracé avant
le xviie siècle donc rien à l'époque des
celtes rien à l'époque des romains rien
à l'époque médiévale
et on a même à monsieur joseph ban qui
détenait qui note qu aucune source dans
la région y compris à une description
très détaillée de 1617 de fait référence
à ces géants ah bah ça plus haut que ça
bon visiblement on peut pas le prouver
on peut pas prouver l'absence d'une
structure mais ça plutôt que ça quand
même ça donc c'est quand même dommage
être représente-t-elle hercule le héros
mythique
c'est dommage quand meme de de base et
sa réflexion champ des possibles
euphorique tonnes 85 mètres de la tête
aux pieds
émerge d'une colline anglaise comme un
témoin géant d'une époque révolue
ouais ouais mais c'est de même que je
sais pas comment on écrit wilmington
mais bon voilà quoi s'est dit si c'est
la même chose
ah ben voilà stonehenge est différent
est une spécialiste reconnue du folklore
anglais
voilà c'est des gros stonehenge la
logique ça veut dire c'est des gros
cailloux donc c'est forcément des
grosses mas qui les ont transportés je
veux dire à cette époque le pays
s'appelait albion après la chute de 3,1
héros nommé brutus est arrivé ici avec
ces soldats et a décidé de conquérir le
pays
ils se sont battus quelques temps avec
ces géants et ils ont fini par tuer la
plupart sauf un qui l'ont gardé en vie
et qui l'ont surnommé edawgs magog
il mesurait trois mètres cinquante un
combat à mains nues l'a opposé à cornes
et us
le duc de cornouaille à chacun d'entre
eux a pris alternativement le dessus et
gog et magog a réussi à lui casser
quelques côtes
ivre de rage quand les gosses à
empoigner ce géant de 3 mètres 50 et a
couru le précipité du haut de la falaise
le géant s'est écrasé sur les rochers en
contrebas
school ce torero ben je vous renvoie ma
remarques sur les trous du cul et les
légendes de géant voilà eu au moins au
moins je suis je suis un peu déçu je
pensais qu'ils allaient dire que les
gros cailloux ça peut être charriés que
par les gros les gros bras les géants
sont également présentes dans la
mythologie de stonehenge probablement le
plus célèbre josy mégalithique dans le
monde
peut-être pas pour les bonnes raisons
ces immenses pierre les plus grandes
mesures 9 m et pèse 50 tonnes ont été
dressés ici il y à des milliers d'années
je suis d'accord avec un britannique
appelée ce siècle de pierre la danse des
géants et croyaient qu'ils avaient été
érigés par des êtres exceptionnels
certes mais l'origine de stonehenge et
la méthode utilisée pour dresser ses
pierres demeure mystérieuse peut être
devons nous tourner vers la légende pour
tenter d'y percer abbas et il en fait
c'est encore mieux qu'ils ont fait c'est
vous c'est encore pire
c'est encore pire que de dire que c'est
des géants qui l'ont fait ils disent non
c'est des êtres surnaturels
non mais c'est des êtres surnaturels qui
aurait construit un cercle de pierres
donc c'est encore pire que dire que
c'est des géants là il commence à nager
dans la contradiction maintenant donc
ils voulaient nous démontrer qu'il y
avait des géants maintenant ils nous
disent que c'est des technologies
surnaturel gollum illuminati vient à moi
gollum illuminati vient à mon aide
démontrent leur la lumière je t'en prie
je t'en prie alors igolo me luminati
damien et les gros cailloux
voilà allez voir la vidéo de gollum
illuminati où l'on peut voir où on peut
voir laissez-moi vous montrer que c'est
quand même formidable
des gens des êtres humains de taille
normale charrier des gros blocs de
pierre donc ici à un bloc de pierre de
12 tonnes avec une grande facilité parce
que quand on s'y met à plusieurs tout de
suite c'est vachement plus simple et oui
en 6 mai à plusieurs tout de suite c'est
vachement plus simple de charrier des
objets regardez là encore sur l'île de
pâques un gros mot haye de 12 tonnes
alors c'est pas la taille des moreuil
ainsi car évidemment ici 25 tonnes voilà
vingt-cinq tonnes et il y en a même dont
boulot c'est de rester debout sur le
caillou tellement c'est facile vous
voyez un peu la logique là maintenant on
tire des cailloux de très grosses
tailles et regarder tout ce qu'ils ont
c'est de la corde et des bouts de bois
aucun souci absolument aucun souci je
crois qu'il ya même un endroit où on
voit des enfants
tu veux aller là il le dire le haut
d'une falaise
j'ai pu me semble qu'il ya un moment
dans la vidéo on voit des enfants tirer
un mégalithe donc non il n'y a rien de
gharyane surnaturel
alors après dresser des pierres là c'est
encore mieux là je vous renvoie vers new
tech et son article qui s'intitule le
reportage en mousse
mieux tech la révélation des pyramides
voilà c'est ça que je cherchais tout à
l'heure la révélation des pyramides
donkey et new tech a fait à des bonnes
cage un peu à la audio connard enfin il
était à nos dieux connard avant l'audio
connard newtech peut-être que c'est pas
votre génération
mais en tout cas voilà il a fait un
magnifique des bonnes cage qui mérite
d'être lu
je pense avec énormément de
condescendance si vous trouvez que je
suis un connard condescendant
sérieusement à les voir aller voir
newtech parce que là là vous voulez de
la condescendance il y en a oui le voilà
pardon qui était passé devant sans la
regarder comment construire stonehenge
dans votre jardin
jamais en 360 regardez le monsieur up
donc le mec il a que du bois et de
l'ingéniosité 1up un bout de bois des
contrepoids et regarder à chaque fois il
rajoute heures il utilise les
contrepoids pour arriver à soulever
cette énorme mégalithes bail à ces
gosses le tout tranquille il continue
continue et au bout d'un moment il a
juste de la ficelle de l'eau enfin rien
de rien d'impressionnant
un officiel de l'eau et de cette façon
il a fini par compter un mégalithe voilà
je veux dire c'est pas rien
d'exceptionnel
pas on est bien d'accord que ce monsieur
est extrêmement ingénieux il est
extrêmement ingénieux mais mais il n'a
rien d'autre que de l'ingéniosité donc
c'est pour ça que je disais c'est super
raciste de dire que sous prétexte que
des gens sont pas des européens et que
du coup ils ont pas notre technologie
ils sont pas capables de faire des
grandes choses
c'est pour ça c'est parce que voulez
vous niez à ces peuples l'ingéniosité
nécessaires à la construction des aux
exploits qu'ils ont accompli quoi donc
non allez vous faire [ __ ]
voilà à la durandal va te faire [ __ ] à
ridley se trouve sur les hauteurs du
golan à 80 km de damas là on commence à
toucher à l'archéologie israélienne
estime qu'il a fallu que ça devient
délicat pour l'édifier il rappelle
étonnamment le site de stone est des
pierres en rond c'est tout de son vieux
d'environ c'est comme les pyramides les
pyramides se ressemble vachement à
travers le monde où il n'y a pas 36
façons d'empiler des cailloux en
triangle de stonehenge
les gens associent qu'il gueule à
l'existence de géant et c'est encore des
légendes de géant aux journalistes me
référence daniel hermann un archéologues
israéliens inspecte une tombe
fraîchement ouverte
à pour une fois on aurait un vrai
archéologues qu'est ce qui va nous dire
[Musique]
c'est de toute évidence la tombe de
quelqu'un de très grands il suffit de
voir la taille des dalles utiliser cela
a dû nécessiter et nourrissez des
grosses dalles donc c'est un gros mec de
dans zola oui c'est cela oui
tradi dans les pyramides vu la taille ça
va vraiment être des gros gars à
l'intérieur des pyramides à wau lorsque
les israélites sont venus ici importante
avec la bible ces constructions
existaient déjà et ils les ont ils ont
donc essayé d'identifier ce site en
disant que cette région se trouvait sous
la coupe de haug souverain du bas chan
dans le deutéronome il est je cite
encore une citation de la bible du bas
chan était le dernier survivant des ré
fine réanimer le mot hébreu
bon j et si c'est écrit dans la bible
c'est forcément vrai ce qui nous amène
finalement tout le reste de cette de ce
reportage parce que pour l'avoir vu une
fois déjà je préfère les surfaces de
notre plat tout le reste de ce reportage
struction gigantesque a annoncé aux
milliers d'années loi ce reportage c'est
pour dire que voilà la bible dit qu'ils
avaient des géants donc finalement il y
avait des géants toi la bible dit vrai
puis voilà on sait pour prouver que la
bible dit vrai puisque le monde
ressemblait au site et que nous voyons
un machu picchu hanako sackey wamala je
pense que thierry jamin sort de ce corps
qui ont édifié toutes ces constructions
à l'aide de blocs massif de 250 ou 500
tonnes on trouve des ruines
impressionnante dont l'échelle défie
l'imagination en de nombreux endroits
d'amérique centrale et des bavoirs une
cathédrale mec même les septs a été
construit avec du bois et des cordes
mais de l'ingéniosité aussi sérieusement
sur l'île de malte en méditerranée court
encore l'histoire ancienne selon
laquelle cet endroit était l'ultime
bastion des géants en europe
c'est cela eric von daeniken
explorateurs et auteur à succès a passé
la majeure partie de sa vie à étudier
les structures mégalithique dans le
monde explorateur et auteur à succès
encore une grande autorité qui
appartient d'un lointain passé
personne ne sait quand exactement
du moins 5 millions dans jésus christ
est un des temples aux goudes ou portent
encore un nom explicite le temps que des
géants comme je l'appelle ici une
légende locale dit que ce temple a été
construit par la géante suna ces blocs
sont si énormes si vous me direz en
france on a des tas d'endroits qui ré
qui font référence au diable la hottée
du diable près de fère en tardenois on a
le rocher aux dragons à aix en provence
est ce que ça veut autant dire que le
diable et les dragons ont marché sur
notre sol
ouais mon nom aucun être humain aurait
pu les déplacés confère la vidéo de
gaulle aux minimes et n'attire aucun ne
la voyant être du lac titicaca
on prive de gigantesque plate forme de
pièce la plus grande devait faire 29
mètres de loin et son poids était évalué
à 900 tonnes nous sommes à un manga qui
se trouve à 4000 mètres d'altitude dans
les andes
ce qui veut dire qu'il n'ya aucun arbre
pas de bois rien il n'est pas possible
de transporter une plateforme de 900
tonnes sans rouleaux de bois et même
avec des rouleaux ce serait extrêmement
compliqué j'aurais envie de dire que
c'est un point valide éventuellement
pour une fois pour une fois au moins il
fait une hypothèse correct à ce petit
détail près 1 que bon il ya un truc qui
s'appelle le commerce on retrouve on
retrouve au moyen-âge des bijoux
musulmans d'origine musulmane arabe jeu
parmi les vikings par exemple donc au
nord de l'europe par exemple de dire
tout les soieries qui était qui était si
prisée des européens à l'époque
médiévale venez de de chine
bon voilà encore une fois on y la
capacité des gens de l'amérique du sud à
savoir faire du commerce avant que les
européens arrivent
voilà un racisme tout ça tout ça bref je
rajoute pas ce sont du fait des choses
que l'on peut observer touché
photographie mais nous n'avons aucune
explication
il est certain que je n'étais pas
capable de les déplacer
il est certain que ces gens étaient bien
trop con pour bouger des cailloux et
encore moins pour les empiler la vache
qu'est ce qu'il faut pas subir c'est
bien en de nombreux endroits sur la
terre on trouve des structures qui
pourraient être associés à des
extraterrestres à une technologie que
nous ne comprenons pas à leur tour des
extraterrestres ou des germes et autres
géants aux technologies secrète
sérieusement à accepter ce genre
d'explications sans sourciller certains
crétins moutons broutent rucks auteur à
succès d'un ouvrage sur les architectes
de l'ancien monde d'accord de jtekt
encore un écrivain à succès ont
construit et on précise à chaque fois à
succès parce que sinon ça veut dire que
c'est juste quelqu'un qui écrit de la
merde là s'il a du succès c'est qu'il
n'est pas c'est que c'est pas le mauvais
bout leur forcément c'est selon ils ont
sérieusement rue des édifices que nous
ne sommes pas capables de reproduire
aujourd'hui qu'ils appréciaient leur
réalisation alors jusque chez moi
capable de reproduire de un peu un un
peu catégorique gohin à 70 km de
beyrouth se dressent les ruines
imposante de baalbeck a lieu que
mentionne les livres des rois dans
l'ancien testament offre un très bon
exemple de trinité
les plus grands assemblage de pierre
jamet utilisés dans le monde pour une
construction des pierres si imposante
qu'on ne sait même pas leur poids réel
elles ont été extraites d'une carrière
transporté sur 8 km il sait les baleines
non plus on sait pas leur poids réel
c'est juste pour dire que ça veut rien
dire de dire qu'on sait pas leur part et
on n'est pas capable de peser une
baleine c'est juste qu'on n'est pas on
n'a pas les moyens techniques de pesée
des gros trucs bout d'un moment faut se
servir de ça comme argument c'est juste
moisi ça pue 8,9 mètres de hauteur et
ajuster ensemble aussi précisément qu'on
arrive pas je glisse et une feuille de
papier on ne sait pas comment ils ont
fait alors je vais ajusté tellement
précisément à galets enfin je veux dire
il ya des yé veut dire il ya des cabanes
en pierre sèche un peu partout dans le
monde qui sont pas du tout ajusté comme
il faut et malgré tout on peut pas
glisser une feuille de papier entre les
pierres c'est curieux comme le fait de
poser une pierre les unes sur les autres
posez deux pierres les unes sur les
autres ça empêche de glisser une feuille
de papier entre les deux et c'est
forcément surnaturel si cet argument de
merde là je dis oui oui les mecs quand
ils empilent des cailloux c'est pas des
branques et il laisse pas de trou ouais
ouais ça va c'est ça reste cohérent nous
n'avons aucune grue dans le monde de
soulever des poids dès septembre
oui parce qu'on n'a pas la motivation du
bougès des trucs de ceux de cette taille
des récits robe et peut-être que avait
la motivation des divinités par exemple
pas de géant pour le compte du raw en
émeraude ou encore une légende de géant
j'en suis
mais que recouvre vraiment le terme de
géant
ah bah ça c'est une bonne question ça il
de monstres assoiffés de sang comme les
cyclopes de l'eau qu'est ce que tu
définis comme étant un géant
voilà est-ce que huit pieds de haut
c'est assez grand poids de géants ou est
ce que c'est juste un être humain de
grande taille
ça se vend comme tout un chacun pourtant
discrètement les rues de nos villes en
plein jour oh [ __ ]
oh là là ils vont dans un coin dehlingen
vont commencer à considérer les jantes
de très grande taille par butin ans
n'ont donc les gens de très grande
taille en fait c'est des extraterrestres
de gens dont des géants
il ya des gens qui sont génétiquement
programmés pour être de grandes tailles
gens normaux mais porteur de gènes qui
les amène à être très grand et puis il
ya ceux qui souffrent de certains
troubles dont le plus commun ou tout au
moins le mieux connu et l'acromégalie
une maladie qui se traduit par la
production d'une trop grande quantité
d'hormones de croissance ne sont pas de
la même espèce que nous c'est là que tu
essayes vraiment dormir là où qu'est ce
que tu sais le potentiel donc là tout à
l'heure on avait le racisme maintenant
on commence à avoir le génie sme c'est
ça c'est là où vous voulez en venir
qu'est ce que c'est que cette horreur là
ça devient vraiment contrairement à
l'article que j'avais fait la dernière
fois là ça devient vraiment
inconfortable
là ça devient vraiment mesure vraiment
inconfortable parfois que j'aimerais
trous si grands que lui oui
ah ben tiens pour la robert wadlow est
ainsi d'une taille aussi peu courante
s'agit-il d'une caractéristique familial
ou d'un éléments nutritionnels les
personnes de grande taille sont elles
des gens ordinaires en cours en france
et invite au sap espère également de
grands talents
et quand il s'agit de basket ball par
exemple ils peuvent même en tirer de
grands profits ou lalanne et les
véritables géants nom a toujours eu la
vie facile
nous avons ici jack le tueur de géants
présentant sa dernière capture au
souverain oui et ça c'est de ça ces
documents d'époque ça cet individu de
jack le tueur de géants s'était donnée
bien sûr
certains de ces géants ont réussi à
vivre de leurs particularités en
s'exhibant public
on n'était plus très loin de ces
démonstrations de foire comportant un
manque ablement un ou plusieurs géants
oui oui ce que vous êtes plutôt en train
de faire en fait là ça on atteint à peu
près le même niveau de l'absence de
respect même après leur mort ils
continuent parfois attiré les foules à
d'assouan et son mari martin mesure en
tout 2 mètres 30
alors ce géant la seule erreur là j'en
ai parlé ont été présentés comme le
couple marié le plus grand du monde et
ont fait le tour de la planète
deux cigognes n'aurait probablement pas
été de trop pour porter leur nouveau né
qui pesé 11 kg à la naissance ce qui
nous ramène à notre interrogation
d'où vient-il il est disponible en
remontant dans un lointain passé de
retrouver dans leur ligne est une race
de géant
marvin telemann un scientifique qui a
reçu le grand prix de l'institut des
sciences wiseman pense détenir une
partie de la réponse
si nous possédons tous des matériaux
génétiques du premier homme est pas
surprenant de trouver ici et là un géant
vivent parmi nous dans la mesure où un
jeune récessif peut produire un individu
de soi la bullshit génétique j'attribue
bullshit génétique bien joué je n'en ai
pas convaincus approche les 2 m ils sont
très grands là encore une tribu les gens
encore plus grand qui aurait visa comme
toutes ces tribus ont été très primitif
ça sentirait presque encore le racisme
de vancouver au canada d être géant
existait avant et elle est là on
commence on entame vraiment le bullshit
100%
c'est vraiment là que la vidéo entame le
bullshit à 100% religieux là là on
attaque du gros du lourd on en est à peu
près à la moitié est
là ils vont lâcher les chevaux là il je
veux dire à partir de là je crois que
j'ai plus grand-chose à des bunkers
puisque les ficelles qu'ils utilisent
deviennent tellement grosse que ouais ça
vaut même plus la peine j'ai plus de
commentaires à faire
je vais revenir sur une photo qui avait
un petit peu plus tôt la de ceux de ses
deux squelettes de jeu qu'on voyait
côte-à-côte linge et en l'autre pas donc
voilà on en avait parlé dans ce top
science le grand squelette à côté là il
est atteint d'acromégalie
et en l'occurrence l'acromégalie ça se
voit pas ce qu'il a l'espèce de gros
menton l'acromégalie c'est un des
caractères qu'on retrouve chez les gens
atteints d'acromégalie c'est une
mâchoire fortement prononcé donc c'était
une anomalie qui est plus répandue en
irlande qu'ailleurs visiblement
particulièrement en irlande du nord et
il ya des ventes on avait parlé c'est
qu'il y avait des analyses génétiques
qui ont été pratiqués sur sur justement
des squelettes des gens de là bas
atteints d'acromégalie
donc ce squelette il est très bien
identifier là celui qui nous montre en
nous disant où il ya eu des jets au
machin bidule
c'est un squelette très bien identifiés
qui appartient à monsieur qui s'appelle
charles bayon et qui se trouve au musée
de l'ombre et qui a vécu au xviiie
siècle et pilaf voilà il je veux dire
qu'est ce que vous lui en voulez il est
juste des justes malade c'est juste un
squelette d'une personne malade
pourquoi vous nous le montrer en nous
disant les années à les géants peut-être
une race différente
au rayon les géants une race différente
maintenant ça va fumer les gars regardez
le bullshit biblique c'est parti
c'est parti qu'est-ce qui est pourquoi
on est dans la jungle maintenant on en
est et oguchi biblique est il possible
que les conditions environnementales du
passé et puis favoriser le développement
de géorgie nous avons bien sûr c'est
damon fossiles au les fossiles d'espèces
comme des dinosaures se pouvait se
développer jusqu'à atteindre une taille
considérable
certaines espèces comme les dinosaures
voilà des dinosaures c'est une espèce
carbo archéologue et partisans de cette
théorie séduisante mais traire à
l'inversé monsieur carle beau
archéologues qui pose devant un
dinosaure un regardé le magnifique la
magnificence de ce décor bassil est
vraiment archéologues il y connaît rien
voilà il n'a pas il a pas de pertinence
à parler de dinosaures monsieur carl
gourgues l'optimisation génétique et la
manifestation de ce que l'organisme
possède de mieux au niveau de l'adn et
qu'il peut exprimer pleinement en raison
de conditions atmosphériques favorables
ouais si tu es bien aurait été plus
grand site a beaucoup d'oxygène tes plus
grands
pourquoi pas à se détendre en fossiles
dont nous disposons on sait aujourd'hui
que des arbres pas de quoi pas de quoi
atteindre 5 mètres de haut quoi avec une
croissance très supérieure à celle
qu'ils connaissent actuellement
abbassi les séquoias géants sont géante
puis que ce phénomène en suggérant que
les conditions environnementales à ce
qu'ils disent et des séquoia
ils ont plus d'oxygène ils ont plus de
soleil donc ils sont plus grands ah oui
ça s'applique complètement aux humains
sont complètement été propice à une
croissance exceptionnelle
ah oui
dans ces conditions les plantes et les
animaux vivaient plus longtemps et est
beaucoup plus grand que c'est
précisément ce que nous constatons avec
les fossiles
on n'a aucune preuve de sa croissance de
ça même que tous les organismes vivants
aujourd'hui nous avons des animaux qui
représente une stature de 2 mètres 40 à
2 mètres 70 alors que leurs ancêtres
mesurait entre 4 mètre 80 et si m
regardez le cas d'un insecte comme la
libellule aujourd'hui une libellule a
une envergure d'environ 10 cm dont les
fossiles retrouvés son ancêtre le mécano
robcis présentait une envergure de 1
mètre 50 dans le passé tout est plus
grand je pense que dans de meilleures
conditions
alors là et dans le passé tout était
plus grands voilà l'argument du monsieur
dans le passé tout était plus grand
parce qu'il y avait des meilleures
conditions environnementales alors je
t'annonce gros jarre que dans le passé
ça veut rien dire
il n'existe pas que deux unités de temps
dans le monde une unité qui
s'appellerait le présent et l'autre qui
s'appelle le passé le passé géologique
c'est quelque chose d'assez
monstrueusement énorme ça représente 4
milliards d'années il ya deux il ya eu
du tout en 4 milliards d'années du chaud
du froid beaucoup d'oxygène moins
d'oxygène
là en l'occurrence ce mec il veut vous
faire croire que megan europe 6 donc là
où mais gagnera connaissez mieux mais
gagnera des libellule géante du
carbonifère qui ont vécu donc il y a
environ 323 160 millions d'années si je
ne m'abuse ont côtoyé le l'ancêtre de
l'éléphant le dino terium des dinos
terium dont on a parlé tout à l'heure il
noté rien n'est pas exactement ancêtres
est plutôt cousin mais admettons donc il
a fréquenté le dino terium qui vivait
entre 5 et 15 millions d'années 1
donc on est quand même un ordre de
grandeur complet en plus jeunes et
évidemment comme il nous parlait des
dinosaures ils veulent nous faire croire
que tout ce beau monde a vécu en même
temps que les dinosaures ce qui n'est
pas le cas non plus mais gagnent roi est
bien plus ancienne que les dinosaures et
dino terium n'a jamais croisé le moindre
dinosaures puis en tout cas pas de
dinosaures qui ne sont pas des oiseaux
évidemment mais jamais de dinosaures
géants en tout cas puisqu'il avait déjà
disparu à son époque
depuis plus de 50 millions d'années donc
ce monsieur essaye de nous faire prendre
des vessies pour des lanternes
voilà en nous disant oui vous regardez
on trouve des gros fossiles ah oui mais
enfin des fossiles on en trouve aussi
des petits et puis des conditions
environnementales par le passé il y en a
pas eu qu'une enfin je veux dire
remontait au moyen-age et vous avez le
petit air glace le petit âge glaciaire
remontait à l'époque romaine et on
faisait pousser des fraises en écosse
remonter encore plus loin et vous avez
vous étiez à la période glaciaire et
remonter encore plus loin et puis bah là
c'était l'époque
enfin je veux dire on porte trop les
périodes glaciaires déjà il ya eu plein
de l'internât sierre il ya même eu un
interglaciaire où on a eu des
hippopotames ans à londres veut dire il
n'ya pas il n'y a pas juste deux époques
il n'y a pas juste maintenant et avant
sauf et c'est là où justement je disais
que l'on part dans le délire biblique
parce que c'est ce qu'ils vont faire
sauf si vous considérez qu'évidemment la
terre assimilant et qui s'est rien passé
d'autre que ce qui s'est passé dans la
bible ce qui est devant nous expliquer
les gens vivent et non seulement plus
longtemps mais était également plus
grand donc ça veut dire aussi j'avais
pas capté mais ça veut aussi dire que
les gens qui sont très grands
aujourd'hui les géants ça veut dire
qu'il lit ils vivent dans de meilleures
conditions atmosphériques
bah oui bah oui ils disent dans des îles
ont une petite bulle d'air autour de la
tête dudit vite vu qu'ils sont très haut
donc ils sont grands parce qu'ils sont
géants y songer ans parce qu'ils ont des
mêmes conditions atmosphériques parce
qu'ils sont très haut
un magnifique serpent qui se mord la
queue moi aussi je peux faire des
théories pourri sérieusement simplement
parce que les conditions atmosphériques
ne le permettrait pas connerie conneries
la girafe et l'ailé les girafes les
éléphants sont déjà plus grande que la
plupart des dinosaures
c'est pas parce que tu focalise sur les
grands dinosaures que ça veut pas dire
qu'il y avait pas beaucoup plus de
petits dinosaures
et voilà ça y est on nous parle du génie
on nous parle du déluge ça y est donc
volaille on avait une magnifique
magnifique boutade sur voilà il ya un
avant et un après il ya juste le il ya
le maintenant pas non il y avait lieu
maintenant et le avant il ya que deux
périodes de temps et en fait ça veut
dire avant et après le déluge
voilà là là les masques tombent 26
minutes et enfin les masques tombent
puis bal à partir de là enfin j'aimerais
bien regardé la fin mais je commence à
être un peu à court de temps il ya la
larme qui va sonner bientôt avec la
chance que j'ai énormément nettement
voilà après ça le reportage il revient
plus sûr de la paléontologie fait que
construire des théories bullshit sur
théorie bullshit sur théorie bullshit
voilà il se hisse sur les épaules de ces
crétins qui vient d'interviewer pour
aller nous dire qu'en gros si on nous
parle de géant dans la bible c'est que
ces géants doivent être vrai voilà donc
fatalement si ce que si la bible a dit
vrai à propos des géants c'est que
forcément j'étais les géants exister
c'est que c'est que forcément la bible
dit vrai c'est que la bible dit vrai
pour tous j'ai de celle avancée
formidable c'est que ça veut dire que si
toute la bible est vrai prix bas et à
toute la science est fausse voilà donc
comment on s'est parée d'un vernis deçà
de science pendant allez mettons 27
minutes pour au final terminer là dessus
quoi les airs au final terminer sur un
douchez biblique et là où c'est
formidable c'est qu'ils vont finir par
se mordre la queue encore une fois ils
vont patauger dans leurs cohérences dans
les incohérences qui crée en finissant
par nous dire que du coup il ya eu des
géants
il est possible que ces géants étaient
créées par des extraterrestres voire
même sont des extraterrestres et ses
géants l'existence de ces géants
confirme que la ville que la bible est
vrai donc ce qui est dit dans la bible
est vrai ouais sauf que sauf que si
c'est les extraterrestres qui ont créé
tout ou partiellement les humains il ya
quand même un gros passage de la bible
qui vous y ayez dans leur histoire
gigantisme il ya quand même un énorme
passage de toute cette histoire qui est
passée à l'as donc au final
si dieu a créé l'homme mais que les
extraterrestres ont créé l'homme
en gros il ya au moins une des deux
hypothèses qui est fausse ou alors dieu
est un extraterrestre mais là on
commence à aller un peu trop loin
bon bref voilà j'ai coursé pour ses
trente minutes presque 30 minutes de
souffrance face à ce reportage
j'irai pas plus loin non pas parce que
j'en ai marre de souffrir mais
réellement parce que en réalité parce
que à partir de maintenant je n'aurai
plus rien à dire en fait il se met à
partir sur des spéculations biblique à
deux francs enfin voilà des
interprétations d interprétation
littérale de la bible qui ne mènent à
rien et puis je connais pas si bien la
bible que ça donc au final voilà donc si
vous voulez me voir plus payer pour mes
péchés et que vous voulez me punir lors
d'un troisième épisode pour ne pas avoir
fini cet épisode là et bien je vous
invite à le faire savoir dans les
commentaires
merci à tous et prenez soin de votre
karma